chris hardwick who'll be in Caroline how
are you okay cool are you I think you
know their ticket to value tonight
tomorrow Saturday or at Comic Con as
well are there even tickets am is by the
way on the screen hey what are you doing
on the screen I'm good I mean I'm in the
closet but they make me stay in there
I'm not allowed to share the room which
I I like your your really cool sound
foam in the back there yes you know what
it looks like it looks like you're in
the matrix
you've been deemed in the matrix and
that's your weird like neutral
background I'm just in a nondescript
kind of you know center yeah you need to
put your you need to put your Sun blades
on your face and some sort of cool
jacket and then just start doing high
kicks yeah for gym just for gym I would
like to say is this streaming anywhere
you and the booth or is this just for us
you know it'll be on I mean we were when
we make the video it'll oh good yes yeah
there are there are tickets for
Caroline's Thursday through Saturday
night tomorrow Saturday you don't
hosting this Walking Dead thing yes sir
at the theater the Hulu theater about
theater yeah and was it was it someplace
smaller first they move it there it was
all well it's it's been at that space I
think it just used to be called like it
had a Madison Square Garden Alec they
move the the event they actually change
the name of them no no they changed the
name of the venue but it's the same
venue that it's been for the last
several years how many years it has that
has all galaxies in the lead the British
lead [ __ ] okay Andy Lincoln and ruling
yeah how long has he been out of walking
this is the first full season without
him yeah he he left halfway through last
season and this is the first full season
without him but he but they're doing a
movie so they're doing like a Walking
Dead theatrical movie that's coming out
the universal and Norman Reedus is kind
of the is is the kind of like the leader
now I suppose that I mean it is still an
ensemble cast but I guess yeah if you if
you wanted to I mean that that seems
like a first Carol still in the fire was
still there no Carol no she's the best
she was on a boat now she's now she's
she's back around so he's in some weird
place by herself so what are you doing I
stopped watching a couple year
what he doing go hang out with the rest
of the group she was somewhere else yeah
I know
no you know she's a loner she's a loner
I guess so yeah you've got new have you
ever been at a point as long as the
show's been on where you go you know I
think I'm starting to lose interest a
little bit here in this show but that's
bad for business
let me get myself reacquainted with well
I just have such a different
relationship to the show than anyone
else because it's true for me it that
should I've been with that show for nine
years and that shows went on for ten and
so I am so close to it it's like my
family so I can honestly say and I've
said this before they were like you're
full of [ __ ] right never fallen off the
I've never fallen off the train on that
show I I feel so close to it and there
are always things about it that I love
so I you know I don't know people might
say that's mine yeah but it is but it is
like a part of my yeah it's probably
different cuz you know all them and like
your going week by week knowing you're
gonna talk you're looking at probably
differently than the casual fan you know
you're gonna be interviewing the people
who are it's it's a different
relationship though you're right yeah
and also you know that my kind of my
take on things is I'm like especially
with that midnight or the podcast or
whatever I really am NOT like I just I'm
not someone who like shits on stuff like
it's just not my I don't know I feel
like I see there's my quality of that in
the world if you if you watch me to go
this guy doesn't [ __ ] on anything
there's a lot of people who will to
satisfy that edge form you know I at
midnight so off the air because I was on
it a lot doing that show one of the few
guys that would have me back oh you
killed every time you know you killed
that show was so made for you and I I'm
miss I don't miss the schedule but I
miss the show I miss the and I also miss
you know just as a comedy fan just the
discovery platform for comedians and a
platform for comedians to be able to go
on and be themselves without burning
through their material and be able to go
out and use the show to sell tickets on
the road and you know it's I really miss
that there's not a lot of places on TV
anymore for comedians it was a weird
creative every tiling every Univ weird
of questions and like the places you
were going and have to compute your mind
we'd have to work a certain way it
wasn't a typical no-collar it was really
fun to do no no you were great at it and
I'm so so sorry
anymore but I every once in a while I'll
sort of poke around and go we should do
this show again come on yeah David must
have loved having you on it couldn't be
that expensive a show to do I know it
was a really cheap show to do
I mean comparatively it was an
inexpensive show to do for for a you
know daily show and you were doing how
often do you tour like were you on the
road a lot doing stand-up or just
playing happen to be somewhere no I'm
I'm I'm on the road
it sort of cools off a little bit when
talking dead comes back around because I
our shows live on Sundays with the
exception of this Sunday the premiere we
pre-taped so I was able to come to
Caroline's but in general I can't really
fly back live on a Sunday because if I
miss a flight or flights canceled then
I'm kind of [ __ ] so I so I'm off a
little bit but yes I'm gonna probably do
like 20 or 30 dates next year and I have
a few more dates the rest of this year
yeah it's nice to be able to go out on
the road but it just sucks when you're
panicking about getting back for
something it's like you're better off
just staying yeah how often how many
dates a year at least twice a month
sometimes three but again it got to be
so exhausting after a while I was like I
got to slow down a little bit doesn't it
make you understand why comics that we
love we were growing up and then you
don't see him as much later go like yeah
because they probably got comfortable
and didn't want to be in a [ __ ]
airport
yeah and they just it was like God that
cuz when you're on stage is the best but
everything around that is like I gotta
go on this plan i disguise coughing on
me and the bottle feel good my throat's
sore I got it you know when you're on
stage is the best but getting there and
hold sucks Joe's not sold out [ __ ]
there's nothing more there's nothing
more of a glaring like how am i doing in
my career like ticket sales just you
know it's like some some shows are full
and some shows up
and that's just kind of how it goes
sometimes you just have to get okay with
it because I mean when you have a number
like that and you're getting that number
every single weekend you're not meant to
have updates every single weekend with
how you're doing like should I be bad
for your brain well so you know the
truth of the matter is anyone who comes
out to see you you know it's like if a
show is not full I don't get onstage you
go with the book it's like but these
people did show up and so I'm gonna
perform for them like there's a thousand
two thousand people here cuz they came
you know but there is no you're right
there's no sure way if there's no lying
in that like there's no lying that's
like when you go and there's a 500-seat
room and there's a hundred and thirty
people there's this there's this minus
this equals me because there are so few
ways to really figure out how we're
doing in this business it the metrics
are right it's like and that's why I
think so many comedians like so many
performers can get so weird about stuff
because it's not like working in a
traditional industry where you get to
this level and then you get a promotion
and then you get to this level and you
get a raise then you get a watch and
then you it's just like you're all the
time we're going am i ok how am i doing
what's you know you'll never be a
partner like you know in the firm like
that's at the top of the law firm is
you're a partner there's no there's not
there's none of that here the great and
almost sad but comforting thing about it
is that even guys who if they sell
15,000 tickets in a city are like I
didn't sell 24 this other person sold
that sold out an arena you know so it
never meant allottee you really have to
figure out if it's just in your own head
it's comforting to you because you're
like oh even those people are feeling it
but it's also this level of no matter
how big I get this will never go away
well it also and also um it also shows
you that when you try to place your
worth your value and external things a
arming percentage of the time they will
let you down and also you know the
external world is fluid you don't have
control over it and so you just get
you'll just torture yourself I mean like
2009 or 10 I did a show at the Laughing
Skull and
Lanna which is like a 75 seat room so
you do two or three shows a night I did
that me and Nick DiPaolo did that
together it's really it was really fun
but what but for like a second show like
on a Thursday or something two thousand
nine or ten literally ten people showed
up and my first reaction was well now
this is a license to hate myself yep
and then I thought you know what though
how [ __ ] fun is this and so I just
brought everyone from the audience up
one at a time and made it like gave them
all their own talk show and this one of
the most fun shows I had ever done but
if I'd had a shitty attitude about it
would have been miserable right I just
you just got to adapt and and have fun
see the problem is I put every ounce of
my self-respect
on external things nothing it's really
difficult because maybe it feels good
when something happens yeah when you get
it whatever it is like [ __ ] that's I
feel great but also if you know I feel
like if from a young age we were able to
find our self-worth internally and
didn't need the external world we
probably wouldn't have become comedians
it's a great point so Jim you don't get
a personal satisfaction going home and
sitting alone nude in your apartment no
I don't sorry I got this great I think
it's from a Kickstarter but I got this
chess board called square square off or
square up and it basically is an app
that's connected to a board and the
board has automated pieces and so they
you can play against the computer and
the pieces move themselves and also if
you have the app I can play against you
and you'll have the physical board and
the pieces will move and it's really
really fun
that's amazing no I have not heard of
that but that's something I would get
because I the tactile of actually
holding chess pieces I haven't done in
so long we're off it's called square off
oh I will get and it is really it's
really fun and and yeah of course you
can play on your phone you can play I
mean like you can play a chess program
on your phone your computer but but
really play like what being able to see
the pieces move and manipulate them in
real time is really fun but it doesn't
tell you where to move them it actually
moves them for you well you move your
piece and then the computer moves it to
piece but if I'm playing you via the app
then the board will move as you move so
I will get I will get to play you and it
you know in a different City but the
pieces will move like we're you know
like we're sitting it
take a piece off the boys you have to it
slides it off so it'll it'll it'll slide
it off the board to the like I can take
a piece and put it off to the side but
it will also take a piece and move it
off to the side
wow I really want to get that because
that's the one thing I haven't done is
uh I haven't I haven't physically held
chess pieces and I'm a very very average
player but I still love ya won't buy the
park all the time I always look at those
guys yeah I don't know why I don't play
like I know I'm gonna lose who gives a
[ __ ] I just don't do it you know why cuz
it because basically the like Park chess
is really interesting because of the
heckling there's like a whole other
psychological game that happens with
Park chess that's fascinating played it
no but I've watched a lot of it and it
and it is it's so much fun but it but
when you but I feel like if I sat down
and I was thrust into it I would just be
so stressed I would forget well I don't
know which piece you know and they're
all good play they're amazing oh they do
that's all they do all day long and yeah
it's a whole it's a whole different it's
a whole different lifestyle did you
watch any I don't watch it but I did
kind of follow the last championship
that went down to like Thea what do they
call it at the end when they had like
the [ __ ] no sudden death almost I
don't know Magnus Carlsen
he's like barely held on right it was
did he not was it did someone not show
up for something was there some kind of
weird did he not play in something
recently I don't know no I don't know
did he win he won yeah he's still
jacking his name is I think but yeah
I've have to go like to some like sudden
death thing like which I guess was
really exciting I wonder if you know the
idea of living in your own head too much
at the time I wonder I would love to if
someone's ever done like a psychological
dive on like do chess players kind of go
off their rocker at a certain point in
their lives because given their six
because you're so much in your head all
the time and is that even if you're
brilliant
how healthy is your ended up okay right
the rare exceptions Alexander Alekhine
was [ __ ] lonely alcoholic I think a
lot of them do kind of collapse now that
they become kind of celebrities you know
like Vishy Anand is probably
he's a god in India and Magnus call
these guys probably a certain amount of
endorsements and money and cash
well I met Kasper he's the first chess
grandmaster I've ever actually met I
went to my friend's James out that sure
interviewed him oh wow James a very good
chess player and he's not over you in
cash probably you want to come so I went
down just to get a brief photo and
handshake and one of the wu-tang clan
guys was there oh wow cuz he was hoping
to play him after banner is that no the
other guy with the Jesus name is yeah he
was there did you and did you talk to
him at all for 33:3 I just stood there I
I haven't been that starstruck in
probably 10 years I just looked at him
and shook his hand and took a quick
fight I didn't know what to say why
don't you invite him on this show
because Jay I didn't want to be you
don't want to poach and James would
probably try to help me if I could he
could yeah but I mean I I he doesn't
know who I am and you know hey come on
Jim and Sam you know he's like one of
the greatest chess players ever is no
I'd love to take a swing the worst he's
gonna say is no I just didn't wanna be a
dick because he was talking to James
sure thing and you know James is James's
played him yeah lost but of course yeah
yeah besides he hates playing average
people well I mean it's yeah I would
imagine that every day of his life if
people recognize him really yeah you
know we should play you might give every
interview you did they wanted to sit
down and do Walking Dead stuff yeah
thing is I would happily do enjoy at all
but but for that guy you know especially
I mean it's kind of like how I don't
know years ago I moderated a panel in
San Diego comic-con that Harrison Ford
was on and the first person that kind of
to ask a question was like oh hi mr.
Fordham so what would Indiana Jones say
if he met Han Solo and Harrison Ford
just goes ah hello you know I totally
shut this guy down I mean you gotta
laugh yeah I said it but but then I also
think like he's but people have been
asking those questions for you know 40
years almost so of course yeah it's a
fairly terrible question I wanted the
answer but he gave a ferret that's an
honest answer to you would Joaquin
Phoenix on your podcast this week yeah I
did yeah
did you like do you see Joker I'm
assuming I did I liked it I mean it it's
dark you know and you and if there's no
superhero element of it all like you
sort of bring in it's interesting
because you're you you are part of the
story in that you bring in your
knowledge and expectation and
understanding of who the character is
but it's the fact that it is Joker is
almost incidental to the story you know
you're just kind of watching a guy with
mental health issues who sort of let
down by the system and let down by his
family and let down by his friends and
you know he just kind of spits spins out
of control and and of course becomes the
Joker but there's no superhero element
to it at all and it's it's it's dark but
I but I think you know I think Joaquin
will probably get nominated ya hear he's
very good I typically don't love him but
I mean this one I really want to see cuz
I guess everyone's talking about it and
I really I really liked him I didn't
know what to expect and he was he was
really funny and fun and like and like
he's he's a river he likes to I can do
bits and stuff and that really you never
know with people who were you know
considered really serious actors because
you think they're gonna be like I don't
brooding yeah brooding yeah it was not
that way at all he was just thoroughly
Pleasant do you know I think I'd love to
interview I said if we can ever get him
to I would love to talk to Liam Neeson
he seems like a fine he do it Gervase
and he was really funny
oh yes be a [ __ ] fun guy to talk
there are some people a couple topics I
wouldn't bring up but I don't know but I
also think there's a lot of people who
are serious actors that probably have a
little bit of a comedy brain that don't
ever get to express it you know right
and people kind of people always
approach them like they're these super
heavy actors and they probably want to
like have fun and dick around and make
jokes and stuff but just aren't really
afforded the opportunity what was Sid
Haig like he passed away like last week
but he did have 4,000 corpses with him
obviously he was a sweet guy he was you
know I had a blast working with him I I
would see him over the years that I had
conventions or you know at Rob's ambe's
house you know Sid would come by and he
was just he was just a sweet guy thank
you for sticking that knife in Sam's
stomach at Rob Zombie's house he would
love to be a Rob Zombie's house more
than he'd love to be anyway
casual happy thing that you do well yeah
I mean rob was one of the first I mean
you know when I worked at MTV in the
1900s I was a I did correspondents at
the 1995 Video Music Awards hosted by
Dennis Miller just to date that yeah
babe one of my one of my my Aristotle
over here in a do but do you think that
they though it's amazing like that type
of comic hosted and now every comedian
no that's a tough gig man hosting the
VMAs or any of those award show is
really tough and it's because the
audience I was lucky enough to get to
present at the Emmys a couple times and
what I realized on stage because
sometimes you'll see a joke on the show
and you go oh that was really funny in
the audience didn't really give it up
other times
the audience is right right but what I
realize from the stage was oh the
audience is changing constantly because
I just wrongfully assumed all the
celebrities are there the whole time but
the truth is a lot of them come and go
they go to get drinks they sit down for
their awards they go out in the LA I
didn't know that and so there are seat
fillers coming in and so there's
constantly people shifting around at
commercial breaks
it's a melee if you're like I'm sitting
down and then if a celebrity gets up to
go to the bathroom or disappear for a
bit they'll put a seat filler and so the
audience is always in flux and they're
sort of looking around and they're
distracted and so they're it's not like
the ideal audience are comedy which you
need to be focused on the stage and
invested in kind of a you know like you
need an audience to become sort of a
unified organism right and it's not a
unified organism it's constantly it's a
dynamic constantly changing organisms a
great way to I didn't know that you know
I've hosted a couple of award shows but
never on that level and they were not
great shows I mean their award shows are
really hard cuz it's because a lot of
times look most people I don't know if
they want to be in an award show and the
alarming majority of the people are
going to lose so yeah it's just an odd
it's an odd dynamic yeah to do an award
I should relate to them then they would
they should find me their hero everyone
that loses should be like this guy get
him though Jimmy rudely interrupted
Chris Hardwick's Rob Zombie origin story
Oh the origin oh no that's okay I was
just gonna say that I interviewed white
zombie and I I guess my expectations aam
be the bet right and I guess I guess I
oh I just got that joke yeah damn it I
don't - I retro actively do not support
that joke and when we get it I thought
you were talking about and of similar
ilk I thought you were talking about of
between Rob Zombie and the band white
zombie yeah but Rob like I guess I had
expected that Rob was you know I go he's
this rock star this metal guy isn't and
it turned out super funny
it's like hardcore nerd horror comic fan
and we just hit it off right away and he
was it was great we were in friend
friends ever since I like watching him
performing I love him the way I love
other bands but I he's fun to watch live
because he gives his [ __ ] about his live
shows like you watching like that
there's dancing and fire and he's moving
like he never mails it in so he's fun to
watch he was a big fan of Alice Cooper
and that was Alice's stage show and he
was very inspired and by that idea that
the show is like a circus because Rob
the thing that's fascinating about him
is that it's not like Rob's music gets a
ton of radio play and yet he's playing
like he put up a picture from Kentucky
than I there were 40,000 people there
like his tour gets bigger every year
because it's such a phenomenal stage
show and you know like now new young
fans are coming in and people are
bringing their kids he's been touring
for that long and so weird that you meet
people now though they're like they know
him as a filmmaker right you know what I
mean that's wild to me and when they
when he first started doing that people
are like oh was Logan Hrothgar gonna
make movies or whatever you know and now
it's like yeah he's a [ __ ] director and
he's got his audience and I don't know
everything three from hell but it was
super fun what happened to Marilyn
Manson towards that Fall Apart half we
don't know they're still doing their
arses
like the twins of evil that's a great
show yeah it's really going to that show
I think the last time they were on tour
together they got in some kind of thing
in it like somebody going and something
like yeah they end up cancelling a
couple dates but they work everything
out and now they're back on to her again
and everything yeah whatever it was it
all worked out
I got both of those guys live sorry I
like a show you know there's a kiss fan
okay I like a [ __ ] a little bit of a
show well that's what's you know that's
what's great about that kind of like
goth horror rock is that it is
theatrical and when you go you know if
you if you see a good band once you go
that's a great band I don't know if I
need to see him again cuz I get it yeah
but when you know that there's a
theatricality and a real performance to
the show then it's gonna every time you
go it's gonna be fun and surprising and
so I get why they they're tourists just
get bigger and bigger it feels good when
you feel like the person that you paid
to see is putting work into this show
yeah that they give a [ __ ] just as much
as you do yeah for a comedian like guys
like Kevin Hart can do it like where
there's fire and it's just an arena
right but I mean there's no show without
comedian there will not be pyrotechnics
at Caroline's this weekend no no two one
two seven five seven forty one hundred
chris is a really funny stand-up a lot
of times though people say that at Jim's
shows it's like having pyrotechnics the
way he prowls the stage like a panther I
do that and I do this thing where I toss
the mic from left to right and I can't
the time I'm not even looking like it is
like a whole thing I do put out
sometimes not even look down I catch the
mic it's quite a show start putting like
an intermission in your show or like
like stilt-walkers come out and all
sorts of you know like mimes and and in
fire-eaters like what's the shuriken
steinem yeah no no who's this show you
should you uh indigo guy know him my
memories just going in [ __ ] bags to
do that show but you swallow the sword
swallower it was it doesn't in LA all
the time it's he threw himself in the
[ __ ] oh god I don't know who you're
talking about the comedian I don't know
you're talking no no he would do the big
show in LA now it's a very hot show i
bombed the magician no he's a comedian
and he would he threw himself into the
[ __ ] fish tank at like MGM to get
attention oh my god I don't have no idea
I don't either
can you look this up Gabriel Iglesias
snow it's not handing up god I can't
believe it I just see a lot of sites
about the shark reef Bob Kelly I took
pictures of me eating a girl's [ __ ]
after one of these shows it was uh I
bombed I was at the Palms when I did it
the pub's yappy chebychev's madhouse oh
I don't eat yours man I'm sorry that's a
pretty big show I didn't know that
American producer H Brewer master
mermaid themed fish tank at the MGM
Grand
wow that sounds like a really fun show
he had really his shows were always sold
out like it's crazy to be like you know
a dwarf and a guy's sword it was like a
whole show and it's not him and he does
what happened to you after the show
happened to everybody is that part of
the show what do you mean
oh the he was talking about the picture
that you took after the show the memory
that you have from the show oh well I'm
going down on a vagina no that was good
to me I did a really good job can I
answer a question about your today's
your question about that type of show
though you feel like when we were coming
up in comedy that anything that was
remotely theatrical or just not like
telling jokes on stage was sort of
frowned upon like Oh what are you got a
prop bag there and now I feel like
there's more room for you know all
different types of stuff onstage well
this is sudden loose even this would
with such a variety show
like I think comics frowned on any
comedian doing stuff like that this was
more like the sort solid wasn't a
comedian was just a sword swallower
where the dancers or whatever they were
just dancers it was more like a Vegas
variety show right so it didn't feel
like a comedy show not when I was on it
didn't all right it felt like our
talking to the disinterest of Waddy I'll
never forget ice-t just stand there with
coke trying to have fun I'm just
watching me [ __ ] bomb my dick off
like certain types of comedy you know
you must have done colleges right you
must have done colleges in your life I
did boy Rutgers Camden not kind to Jim
Norton well you know you I remember like
years ago when you do it when I do
colleges and you'd show up and they go
okay well you know there's a study hall
so we're gonna set the mic up over in
the corner and there
pa and there is this idea that like
comedy just works everywhere and it's
like guy you know it doesn't need some
conditions to help set the table yeah
for it to work the first time I met
Patrice I was a college it was me as the
opener Patrice as the feature and this
guy Dom fig as the headliner I bombed
horribly Don fig he bombed Eve just as
badly as I did and Patrice bombed
slightly less and this cocky piece of
[ __ ] thought he killed I drove him back
to the city because I got Jamie asked me
to drive him back and he really was just
critical of me and Dom because if the
great said that's how I knew what a
delusional Aditi was a bomb in the
middle of an afternoon in a college I
remember I think maybe one of the one of
the years I did just for laughs in
Montreal I think I did a show that was
there might have been more French
speakers in the audience and and so
everyone every comedian who was real
talkie struggled that show right and
then the last act was like oh my god I
think he like juggled ping-pong balls in
his mouth or something and he destroyed
all the talking comedians were like god
dammit you know that brings out hatred
in comics is out hatred in comedians he
killed like you know from his point of
view he did the right stuff and we were
all wrong sure absolutely but we all
know like in a room while student
together the guy with the ping-pong
balls balls quietly in his pocket
humiliated [ __ ] pile of [ __ ] one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the Sirius XM
app